Welcome to the podcast.
My guests today are Arthur Jones and Giorgio Angelini.
They are the filmmakers behind a new documentary
called "Feels Good Man".
It's definitely one of my favorite films of the year.
It's an absolutely wild, insane ride.
This is a phenomenal conversation
about many interesting things, including internet culture.
I think you're gonna enjoy it.
So hit that subscribe button and that's it.
Enjoy the conversation, "Feels Good Man".
Welcome gentlemen, I'm super happy to have you
guys here today.
Very happy to be here.
Yeah, thank you.
I love the movie, I truly think it's one of the best
documentaries of the year.
So it's exciting to break it down with you guys today.
And I think first, we should kind of synopsize it
for people that have not seen the movie.
So, I guess I can allow you guys--
Sure.
The opportunity to tell us a little bit
about the delay.
You'd think after like months of explaining this
we'd be really good at it,
but it's always very nerve wrecking,
it'd be like, "What is this movie actually about?"
It really depends on the day.
It's about so many things.
Exactly.
It's hard to like nail down specifically what it's about.
I mean, there's things that it's about on the surface
but what the movie is really about is what's going on
beneath that veneer of what's happening specifically
with "Pepe The Frog".
Exactly
Yeah.
And I mean, I think it's that complexity that drew us
to the story initially,
but you know, the inciting incident for the movie
is a pretty simple and kind of weird thing.
It's a single panel of an obscure comic book
called "Boys Club".
And there's this one panel in which Pepe, the frog
which is this anthropomorphic stone green frog character.
That if you haven't seen "Pepe The Frog"
you just stop the podcast and then Google it
and then immediately come back, close that tab.
Come back in two weeks.
You finally wrap your head around what exactly is going on.
After you've taken a disinfection shower
and then come back to the podcast.
But so there's this one panel
of this comic that's done by Matt Furie.
Who's the subject of our documentary.
And in this panel, Pepe is saying, "Feels good, man."
And it's this one single image
of Pepe that was cut and paste out of that image
and then became this like viral phenomenon globally.
And our story tells the very like strange
and unlikely journey of this comic book
character becoming an internet meme that was wildly popular
and then ultimately becoming sort of a tool
and a propaganda sort of tool
for the alt-right and officially designated a hate symbol
by the Anti-Defamation league in late 2016.
And the story is kind of two-fold, it's the story
of Matt Furie who created this with no ill intent
obviously it becoming a meme
and then a hate symbol had nothing to do with him.
And it's the story of him sort of realizing that
and then dealing with it
in the ways that he felt were correct to him.
And then the other part
of the story is about how trolling moved
off of message boards and into mainstream politics
because Pepe was really used as basically a tool for trolls.
And so when we started making the film,
we realized that this could be like a really unique story
because the way that Pepe was sort of like taken
from Matt was a way that we felt like a lot
of viewers would potentially see consensus reality
sort of being stolen from them
in the attention economy.
Right.
And so it was something that also myself as a cartoonist
was excited to just have a movie that talked
about cartoon seriously.
Right.
You know, in the way that like cartoons carry all
of this kind of like visual baggage to them,
that they are these things that are like intellectually
sticky, that people often sort of dismiss, but, you know
they're important and potent and stay with us for decades.
And Pepe was this, I don't know emotionally flexible avatar
that people were using.
And speaking of cartoons seriously,
and as important as they are the panel
in which Pepe says "Feels Good Man"
is in response to his friends making fun of him
for peeing with his pants around his ankle right?
So--
It's perhaps like the most benign like innocent, you know,
ridiculous thing ever.
And the idea that that image could get co-opted
and evolve over time into such a, you know
pernicious icon of regressive culture is baffling, right.
And I just remember personally the first time
I came across "Pepe The Frog" late in the game
was just seeing that emoji popping up
on people's Twitter profiles
and being used in posts that were, you know
very much in the alt-right bent and being confused,
like why is this frog being aligned
with this particular political perspective
doing a little bit of research into it
but still not really grokking what exactly was going on.
And the story that you tell is just so much more astounding
and exasperating than you could possibly imagine.
Yeah and I think that's sort of how I understood
Pepe at the beginning.
Like I had spent a lot of time on Reddit in the early days
and like was familiar certainly with Pepe as a meme
but when Arthur told me that he was starting this project
like it came from a relationship
that he personally had with Matt.
And so like, I felt kind of totally embarrassed
that I didn't know anything about the backstory,
but like in those first early conversations
it was just very clear
that this was such an incredible opportunity to tell
at least what I find like, to be the most interesting kind
of documentaries that are about something on its face
very specific and eccentric and strange
but really speak to like
a broader cultural situation.
Right.
Yeah, in the broadest sense,
it's about how information travels
and shapes culture, right
through the lens of this one specific image, but you know
the idea of the meme, you know,
as it's most broadly defined
and I love this woman that you have on who, you know
the color with all the crazy hair
and everything like that, 'cause she's a character, right.
And she's into like the paranormal and all this crazy stuff.
But the idea--
Susan Blackmore.
The idea of the meme hearkening back to Richard Dawkins
and this book that he wrote
that there are genes that influence human behavior.
And its memes that influence cultural behavior
and evolve over time to, you know
shape not just political philosophy and ideology
but cultural identity
and everything that gets packed into that.
Like the power of that cannot be overstated.
And yet we kind of think of memes as a very, you know
kind of casual, temporal thing.
Oh yeah, we're just beginning to understand
like the true grotesque potential
to like coalesce political bodies
but also be deployed as political propaganda.
There's just so much embedded within the way images
operate on the internet.
Yeah, this has definitely had its core.
The film is like a really immediate study
or media literacy project.
Right.
It kind of in the back of my head
when we were starting at two, I was observing how my father
like I grew up in rural Missouri
and very conservative family--
Evangelical, right?
Yeah, evangelical family, Southern Baptists.
And my dad had been like a Bob Dole supporter.
He'd been like kind of a family values conservative.
And he's a very like moral guy.
Like he's never had a beer or a cigarette, you know
he's someone that really walks the walk.
And I would thought that he would've been shocked
and horrified by Trump.
I would have thought that he would have found Trump's morals
to be reprehensible.
And I was surprised that all of a sudden
he was really kind of completely enamored with Trump.
And I was also surprised how he just got an iPhone
and when it stopped staring at it
he was using the iPhone, like a teenage girl.
Like he was just scrolling constantly
the Fox news media feed.
And it was something that I was kind of trying to like think
about and deal with.
And even though none of that is like in the film
specifically that was the stuff that I was thinking
about as we were beginning to make the film
how can we have this story that's about these?
For me, it was kind of like this twin passion
of like cartoons and iconography
and then also kind of trying to decode what is going on
in the country.
Right.
And so, you know those were the conversations
that Giorgio and I were having about in the beginning
and we thought Pepe was just such an amazing vehicle
for this larger discussion.
'Cause ultimately we can make a movie
about this hilarious stoned, weird frog.
And then we can sort of like within all of that,
have all of this like really kind of important
informational stuff that is pointing
towards a seismic shift in culture.
Social media is changing culture in a way
that we are just beginning to understand, you know,
it "Feels Good Man" is like a cave painting at the beginning
of a new era.
Right.
You know, and I think it's just like the way the internet
is kind of like downloading our psyches into the machine
is something we have to be aware of.
And Pepe is like a way
in which we can kind of like
talk about it.
Right.
It doesn't feel like overly intellectualized
it doesn't feel like, you know, too important.
It's still this kind
of like weird frog.
Right.
And yeah, it was just something
that we just became completely obsessed with over the two
and a half years we were making it.
It also underscores just how strange the whole thing
is because Pepe is this bizarre, you know, figure,
it's like it's this amazing entry point to explore
a very serious subject with this veneer
of kind of lightness
at the same time, right.
So you Arthur, your background is as a cartoonist.
Yeah, like--
Yeah and graphic designer.
So you were friends with Matt, like take us back
to I wanna talk about Matt a little bit,
like and the impetus for the film, you know, at the outset.
Well, to go back to the beginning
is I'd bought his comic book boys club at Quimby's Bookstore
in Chicago, and that's an independent bookstore
and it was a pretty obscure comic.
It's not a comic book store that you would buy
like a Spiderman, you know,
an issue of Spiderman.
Right.
This was more of like a, you know
bespoke kind of indie store.
And I thought his comic was really funny
and I really liked it.
And it had stayed with me for several years.
Just kind of like in the back of my head.
So when I saw Pepe start to pop up on the internet,
I found it baffling.
I wondered if the people who are using it had any knowledge
of its context or the comic.
And then I met Matt when I moved to California
through some mutual friends.
He was friends with my girlfriend, Carrie McLaughlin.
Who's a co-producer on the film.
And actually some of the archival footage used
in "Feels Good Man" was stuff that she had shot.
And we took a hike to a hot Springs.
It took two days.
We hiked out like 10 or 12 miles with a group of friends.
We stayed at a hot Springs overnight.
And then we like hiked back.
And it was something that Matt and I just bonded.
We bonded over cartoons.
We bonded over the things that we were most excited about.
And then we started to run
into each other around Los Angeles.
And when I'd run into him, I would try to figure
out ways to talk about Pepe a little bit.
'Cause I'd see him in the news and be like
"What do you think about this?"
And I could tell that Matt's opinion
about it was still forming.
It was something where initially I think
he just wanted to like ignore it.
And he just figured this was just kind of like part
of the internet that he had nothing to do with.
And then as it started to get weirder and weirder
he just kind of, as a friend just asked me for help
he could see that I was like, maybe thinking
about this a lot and that he trusted me.
And so initially we thought about trying to produce
like a cartoon and the cartoon would be sort of an updating
of boys club.
It be, we would take that as sort
of the initial source material
and then we would tell sort of like a Alison Wonderland
kind of story, where Pepe gets sucked out of the comic book
and then into this like kind of dystopian existence.
And he asked to find his way back home.
And then we pitched that around Los Angeles
and surprisingly no one saw that--
But I watched a little,
the part in the Pepe evolution take place.
This is like 2015.
So like, yeah.
So it's insane
at this point.
Yeah.
It was 2016.
It was a little bit insane for us
to do it for sure.
Right.
Just because you have to realize some people
thought Matt was somehow like a member
of the alt-right.
Right.
They would see his comics.
Of course.
They would just all of a sudden be like,
oh no, no, no, we can't go there.
And that's the thing that's baffling about the ADL stuff.
When Pepe gets listed as a symbol of hate speech
they put his name alongside it, which was confusing
because then it really did align him with that.
And that had to be unbelievably painful for him
but couldn't they just get rid of the reference
to him personally?
They've rewritten--
They have, they have.
The entry a number of times.
And you know, the ADL has, you know
we've talked to them at various points during the making
of the film and they've been pretty generous with us.
I think they were just kind of trying to do
what they felt was best in the moment
and did not think about the repercussions.
I think the issues Matt had with us,
they just didn't reach out to tell him
that this was about to happen.
And all of a sudden Matt wakes up one day
and he's a news item.
And he is obviously like horrified
that his name was attached to this.
And also it's just like, he's trying to eat his career
out basically as an independent cartoonist.
And all of a sudden
if you're the guy that popularized the alt-right if that's
what people perceive--
you are radioactive.
Completely, completely.
And so, you know, that was another motivation
for us wanting to make the film was
'cause we just realized that almost no one knew Matt story.
They did not understand where Pepe came from.
And we thought that like if people understood
the true context for the character and the backstory
that we would basically be able to, like you know,
we've talked about it before
as like kind of like canonized Pepe.
So at least people would know
that if they see a meme of Pepe
that's not the original version
'cause there's been a lot of cartoons
that have been remixed, redrawn in really hateful ways.
Like there's a lot
of like racist SpongeBob--
Right.
On the internet.
But the difference is that yeah
the difference is that there's a huge studio that created it
and everybody has a prior context for that.
But boys club was this hidden little thing
that almost nobody knew about.
So they didn't have that history
to contextualize the whole thing.
No I mean, it's kind of remarkable.
If you look back on it as, you know, the full totality
of the story, like Matt creates Pepe,
what in 2006?
Yeah.
And I don't have the numbers, but I would guess
that Pepe is probably like in the top 10
most recognizable cartoon images across the world.
And it has nothing to do with like a company, just, you know
pumping billions of dollars into it as a brand.
It's just purely in the power of Matt's initial image
and its ability to have like connected
with a particular audience online
and just grown from there and, you know, dimension like it
started off innocently.
Right.
It really metastasized into something much different
but like in a sense
the film was trying to reverse engineer that context
that on the internet, in the absence of that context,
like the hive, mine of the internet
just kind of injected its own narrative into Pepe.
And so I think we're happy to see
that in the release of the film, it's kind of operated
just as we would have hoped that like it's really
that's all Matt's ever really wanted to do
was to tell a story, not to like, I think sometimes
he gets castigated by certain trolls online
for like being naive about wanting to like take back Pepe.
I don't think there's not an interest in taking it back.
It's just telling its story.
Right, yeah, I mean, there is a narrative
that he was somewhat naive and thinking initially that,
you know, it would just go away
until it gets so out of control that he's, you know
realize that he's got to step in and do something.
So the underlying theme is really this journey
from passivity to participation on behalf
of Matt specifically, but also on behalf of, you know
the 4chan community and all these other people
who become activated to participate in the political process
in a way that previously, you know, didn't appeal to them
because of feeling disenfranchised or whatever.
So that's the real power that kind of engine
beneath the whole thing that created this metastasized
you know, icon and also,
the result of the 2016 election in so many ways.
Yeah, I mean Matt sort of alone in that experience,
right there aren't really many other artists
that have had to go through what he's gone through.
And so he's really had to make up the game plan
along the way.
And so as documentary filmmakers, it was really
a gift to be able to capture that sort of coming
off the proverbial couch moment happening
in real time, right.
To really track someone, have to confront something
that they thought would just go away on its own
and really feel like they're kind of this reluctant hero.
And that as filmmakers was really potentially powerful
because I think for a lot of Americans
they might see themselves in him a bit, right.
Like in the way that his artwork
was taken away from them there.
Yeah, like Arthur just mentioned like their sense
of making sense of the world had been taken away from them.
Yeah I mean, you see this guy, you know, this expectation
that he's gonna hire a lawyer, the incident he finds out
that Pepe is, you know, being used in a way
that he didn't intend is preposterous.
It's like, this is, you know, he's a very sensitive
artists seems like a really sweet guy.
Like that's not the kind of guy who's gonna do that, right.
So that stuff costs money, you know?
Yeah, exactly, you know--
Costs a lot of money.
In a weird way, it had to get as bad as it got--
And nobody could have predicted
that anyway.
Exactly, you know, so.
I understand why people might consider Matt naive
but I think it's important to point out that like
obviously this has never happened before
and Pepe has outlived a lot of the platforms
that was even popular on things on the internet do disappear
and Pepe for whatever reason has stuck around now
for more than a decade.
Right.
And so I think Matt initially thinking
that it would go away the same way MySpace
and Friendster did made sense.
And then also it's kind of important to point out
we documented the film is that Matt was a new father
when all of this was happening.
He was a lot more concerned with providing for his family
and changing diapers than necessarily
taking on the alt-right.
Right.
And so he just kind of didn't have like the emotional
or financial bandwidth to deal with it.
And so, you know, I think he's in the film
he realized at a certain point that this obviously
he had to use copyright
because it was kind of the only tool that he had.
But before that, he tried initially to reach
out to his artistic community, to remix
and re kind of meme Pepe in a positive way.
And I think that's the moment
that people often would say Matt was naive
but I think Matt knew that going into it.
And it was a way for him basically just to reach out
to his community in that moment and say like,
hey, I need help.
Yeah.
You know, can you help me?
And it was a way for him to talk to his friends
about it and then for them to make artwork about it.
And it was like a very earnest thing.
Yeah and ultimately something like 500, you know
kind loving Pepes emerge from that.
But you know, that's a drop in the sea of, you know
hundreds of millions of, you know
pernicious versions of that there's that scene
near the end where he's in that, like
it looks like kind of a think tank situation
in San Francisco with all these data scientists
and they're analyzing hate speech on the internet.
And he says, there's like a hundred million store.
It's by far the most, it's like, yeah, there's no way
that you can, he's like I wish you luck with that.
But you know, it was basically like, you know,
this is not the way forward
in terms of like shifting that perspective.
But it's a shame that it, like, it had to get to a point
that it reached such a fever pitch
that this very large and powerful legal institution
that WilmerHale Lewis, Tom Burrows and Stephanie Lynn
were able to come help Matt pro bono.
Right, like it had to get to a point at which a law firm
could see a kind of greater social good
and donating their time to help him.
And without that, I mean, I don't know where he would be.
And it was really like, I don't know if it's bears
mentioning to you that there was this break point
for Matt where, well, I guess now no longer
assistant principal of a middle school in Texas
had published this children's book
that had once again co-opted Pepe,
but in the context of like a pretty racist.
Yeah, that's a bridge too far
where he really got activated after that.
Yeah I mean, it was propaganda directed at four
and five-year-olds, and you know, in the movie
we also showed that Matt is a children's book author
an illustrator and I think he found the fact
that this propaganda was sort of being pointed at
such younger audiences.
He found to be really disturbing.
And it was also just easily accessible on Amazon.
It wasn't just as simple as like asking Amazon
to take down the book.
And so, you know, we've even noticed that like, you know
there's all this bootleg Pepe's stuff, that's on Amazon.
It's actually quite hard to get them to take it down.
You know, none of this is like just an easy process.
It takes a lot of time and a lot of intentionality.
And so he realized that that was kind of the moment
that he needed just to seek out help.
And yeah, luckily he found this law firm
that was willing to do it,
and they continue to kind of fight for Pepe
in various kind of ways now.
I love the arrow shot of the lawyer
coming into the conference room.
That got a standing ovation.
Yeah.
That was, yeah, that was an amazing moment of Sundance.
The Louis, the Bain lawyer there was sitting just down
the road at a Sundance.
And when the hero shot happens, like what happened?
I saw his wife like reach over and like squeezes.
Yeah, there was, but yeah, it was a very validating moment
for them to have like this audience, you know
'cause people are ready in the movie
for something to happen.
Right.
'Cause we do sort of like--
Well, cause it goes to such a dark and despairing place
you know, and I was concerned about that.
I was like, how are you gonna round this out?
Like I wasn't aware of how it ended.
And that was quite uplifting and interesting.
And maybe we should leave that for audiences
to discover themselves.
But, but it is, it does end on a very hopeful note.
But I think what I'd like to do is, is walk through
a little bit of the timeline and the evolution of Pepe
so that people can wrap their heads
around what has happened.
I mean, it basically begins, as you said, with him
uploading a panel from his comic book to my space
it then seems to get adopted by the kind of fitness
subculture on the internet.
Who start saying, feels good man after their workouts,
which is an innocent and kind of fun thing.
And were you able to actually connect the dots
from that back to Matt?
Well I mean, nothing on the internet is a straight line.
It's sort of all spread out.
I mean, you know, we weren't able to connect things back
to like certain people or certain sort of moments on things
but it did seem like there were a few message boards
that one was about mushrooms and that kind of made sense.
And then there was another one that was bodybuilding.com
message board and for whatever reason
that message board has always had a relationship
to the fit message board on 4chan.
Fit is often kind of a board that will introduce
like young guys to 4chan
because it's guys who are like maybe like 13
or 14 and they're looking to just, you know
kind of like shape up a little bit.
So they'll go to fit.
And they'll sort of like, you know, talk to other young guys
about how to lose weight, how to gain muscle,
how to basically just become men in the world.
And so it seemed like that was probably the moment
that Pepe passed
from the bodybuilding forum--
In the 4chan community.
Into the 4chan community.
I remember we we're talking about this,
like COVID tracing, like--
Well you know it's, to extend the evolutionary analogy.
That's like, you know, the waterborne animal
finally climbing on the land, you know,
it was like a big leap in how this thing ends up evolving.
Well I mean, there isn't emotionally linear line.
I mean, I think you can correlate a lot of this, you know
the in-road is through bodybuilding.com
but it like the metastasis happens
really in like understanding the kinds of people
who are coming to those kinds of forums, right?
Like there's of course a huge number of people
who are there just to seek out information.
But then there's also like this kind of other
maybe more pernicious cultural problem,
which is of men who feel like they've been scorned
specifically by women who are coming onto these boards
to kind of share a struggle and feel
like they have to improve their bodies and kind of like
who kind of see the world and maybe binary ways
and feel like that the only way that they compete
is through like improving themselves physically.
And you start to really see how
like the marrying of the image
of Pepe and the sort of catchphrase of "Feels Good Man"
and then these kind of nascent emotional problems all kind
of coalesced at that moment.
Right.
Yeah and on 4chan there's, I mean,
it's a lot of different message boards and each one
of them kind of have their own little communities attached
to them, but there's one message board
in particular named r9k.
And this is a place where a lot of guys
would just go basically to kind of like tell a story
about their rejection.
They would go there to talk about how maybe a girl
didn't sit next to them in the cafeteria
or about how, you know they'd had a one night stand
and then they felt like rejected afterwards.
And Pepe became the kind of like avatar for that.
And it's an anonymous place.
People don't use their faces or names.
And Pepe became a stand in for that.
And so he went from the "Feels Good Man", frog
to the feel sad man frog the symbol of rejection.
And so we used Pepe basically
as this like emotional through line to tell the story.
And as Pepe got angrier, the country was getting angrier.
You know, the country was becoming a place where, you know
outside of the mainstream media, there was this aggrievement
that was becoming slightly irrational.
And so we traced Pepe from the feel sad frog
to the feels bad frog to the mad frog to the smug frog
to Donald Trump.
But I know that sounds like a silly narrative device
but it was powerful for us
because ultimately we're trying to make a film
that tells this emotional journey.
And the thing that's interesting
about Pepe is how people felt attached to the character.
This JPEG really meant something to people.
And when they started to see the mainstream using it
it felt like a personal affront.
They were like,
that's our thing.
Right.
Like how dare you use our thing?
This has been our safe space to share in amongst ourselves.
It's not for you.
And, you know, we found that to be interesting.
Like it surprised me going into it, just the connection
that people were feeling
towards this frog.
Yeah.
There was--
Silly, like as a way to structure
an otherwise super complicated story.
It actually, as soon as we discovered that parallel
it would became an incredibly powerful narrative device.
And just like, like Arthur just said
just tracking the descent of Pepe
into a depravity correlated
so neatly with--
Right.
And then really there's this watershed moment that happens
in 2015 where there's, in the span of two weeks
you have a mass shooting at the Umpqua Community College
in Oregon, which still today is the deadliest mass shooting
in Oregon history.
And supposedly, I mean, this did happen
but we don't know for sure
if the shooter posted it,
but it's in all likelihood.
It seems very likely.
On 4chan, someone posted the day before the shooting
a kind of warning
don't come to this school, my four chain, friends, whatever.
And then it had at the bottom
it was an image of Pepe holding a handgun.
And then the next day the shooting happened.
And then that was sort of the first time
that Pepe really made it into mainstream news.
People referred to him as a Grinch like creature,
but then two weeks later--
And there's a little moment
of like Pepe panic,
Right.
There were a number of colleges that were like, you know
we're like, we're shutting down tomorrow
because we've had this anonymous like threat.
It would be a Pepe image holding a gun
or a Pepe with a ski mask.
Yeah and then two weeks later we had this moment
where Donald Trump retweeted an image of himself
and it as Pepe.
Yes, he retweeted an image of himself drawn as smug Pepe.
So it was Pepe with like the yellow hair standing
behind the sort of podium as if he was at a press conference
in the Oval Office or in the White House.
And so, and it seemed like the media wasn't kind
of connecting the dots
between those two things,
Right.
You would've thought in an earlier era
that would have like--
But it's like he was dipped in 4chan culture,
you wouldn't be able to decode.
Totally.
Exactly.
And that's exactly what it was.
It was a wink, it was sort of like his, a precursor
to the kind of stand back and standby comment.
Right, it was a very deliberate use of a meme
that was trying to activate a certain group online
who they knew was, you know, starting to gain momentum
as a support base for them, right.
Because you have all these kinds of aggrieved men online
who otherwise it's kind of on its face.
It's kind of ironic because like, there are people
who presumably would get bullied a lot in high school
and like here they are supporting someone
who's kind of like, right.
The biggest bully of all, but for them,
it's like their own bully.
Right and they share a sense of common disdain for women,
people of color, PC culture specifically.
And so they like rally around him.
And so that moment that Donald Trump tweets himself
as smug Pepe is kind of like, yeah, you're right.
It went completely under the radar, but it's actually
a incredibly significant moment that really the nature
of politics and trolling
just become like completely intertwined.
Because the aggrievement that's felt on 4chan
there's also kind of an entitlement to it.
People feel as though in a previous era,
they would have had a much different life.
They would have like met a girl in high school.
They would have got a job in their hometown
that the sort of like social options
that people have now because of the internet
means that they will be out of work
and unlove for the rest of their lives.
And this is sort of also happening in parallel
to obviously different parts of the country
feeling as though they're being left out
of the national conversation.
And that part that growing population
of the aggrieved coincides with the maturation
of these platforms that allow these communities
to congregate and unite around these ideas
which is like, you know, that's a very kind
of powerful machine that's humming in the background.
That's basically allowing all of this to percolate
into real life.
Totally I mean, you see, for example
the last Republican national convention
I think was the first time
that the party didn't put forth an actual platform, right.
It was just, if you watched it
it was just like unbridled, unmitigated anger, and it's kind
of situation that we have now where there is no political
discernible political ideology behind it.
The only way to coalesce that body
is through iconography and like Pepe,
it really was became the first vehicle
through which that happens.
And then I would argue like Pepe kind of lost its usefulness
and other things filled in that vacuum,
whether it's like QAnon
and who knows what it's gonna be in 2021.
But these are, this is kind of the world of politics
and memes that we're having to confront right now.
Well, the inflection point where Pepe tips from 4chan
into broader internet culture is super interesting
you know and kind of backing up from that.
You have this neat culture, right?
That not in education, employment or training, right.
Which is like the catchphrase for this 4chan community.
They claim ownership to Pepe, and this is their kind
of safe space for their community, right.
But the minute Pepe migrates outside of that, and people
like Nicki Minaj and Katy Perry and these sort of, you know
beauty YouTubers are doing make-overs in the likeness
of Pepe, that was the ultimate personal affront
to the 4chan community.
And their reaction to that to protect this symbol
was to kind of defame it themselves
so that it couldn't be co-opted
and used in any other context.
So it didn't germinate necessarily
out of a white supremacist anti-Semitic sensibility
that that image was marked up
in that way to prevent it from being stolen and used
in a way that they didn't want it used.
That's true.
It ultimately becomes a standard for that ideology
but that's not how it originated.
Yeah I mean, a lot of it came out of the competition
between 4chan and Tumblr
and Tumblr is not exact I mean,
it's another image posting site
and it's a very inclusive community.
At least it was at the time.
I mean, Tumblr is kind of now faded away a little bit
but it was a very like vibrant, extremely, you know
diverse, very feminist.
And they started to use Pepe.
And that was kind of the moment that 4chan was like,
no no, no, no, you can't go there.
And so their response was actually to kind of like literally
smear Pepe in shit.
Like there was this moment before Pepe became a Nazi
and we don't get it into the movie, but it was just
like the scatological moment where they're just
like drawing the grossest weirdest versions of Pepe.
And so that wasn't politicized in that moment.
But then Pepe kind of makes its way into the politics board
on 4chan the poll board.
And that board was having this moment
where it was getting very fascia.
It was getting like very fascist.
'Cause he had other things like Gamergate
and other sort of exacerbating events online
that were really serving to radicalize people in real time.
But you're right.
I mean, it's like a big critique we'll get sometimes
from 4chan and people is like, you guys know me idiots
like Pepe was never a Nazi symbol.
The media turned him into that.
And it's like, well, yeah, I know we made the film
and like that we tend to agree with,
but you need that point.
It is also the case that it is like a hate symbol
for some people.
And that switch that you're talking about
is really important one, right.
Because you have a group of people who are kind
of responding to the co-opting of their culture
by mainstream culture, which is fairly typical.
I mean, like in the punk movement, the same thing happened
when like, basically Walmart starts selling like, you know,
sex pistol shirts
or whatever.
Yeah.
But like, so that's kind of innocent enough
but then you have the kind of professional racist
and opportunists who see in this kind of opportunity
to take hold of this very powerful icon
that obviously people care a lot about.
And the kind of people that cared about
a lot are aggrieved young white men.
Unlike in the history and lineage of professional racism
like it's always been about how to find these
out of work aggrieved young white men
and tell them like where their problems are coming from
and how to solve them and who to blame.
Right unlike Pepe was this perfect kind of flag
that allowed these opportunists to identify
and kind of radicalize them.
So, you know, both things are true
Pepe is not a hate symbol
but also like people were very eager to turn him into one.
when you see Trump, re-tweeting that image
of him as Pepe, you know, the immediate question
that comes to mind is what is his self-awareness
around that at the time?
Like as he consciously tapped into what that represents?
Is he doing it because somebody in his campaign said,
yeah, you should retweet this.
Like where's his head at?
Well I feel like that's the problem
you have when like, I've got into a lot of conversations
with Trump supporters and there's always this moment
where they have to acknowledge
that Donald Trump's a little crazy.
They're like, yeah, yeah.
He just does some crazy stuff sometimes, but, you know
I know he doesn't mean it.
And so, I mean, he always has this plausible deniability
built into everything that he does 'cause we all assume
that he's a little like unhinged or erratic
or he's up on Adderall at two in the morning,
whatever it is.
But we sort of are able to explain away all
of the terrible stuff that he tweets,
whether that's Pepe or someone yelling white power
at the villages, retirement community in Florida.
And so Pepe is another one of these, you know
plausible deniability moments where it's like
we don't know, we can't understand what he thinks, you know.
But that's kind of baked into Pepe himself, right?
Like you've got the guy, I forget his name.
Who's like, it's always shrouded as a joke.
So you have that kind of deniability as well.
Like this doesn't really mean anything.
We don't intend it seriously because it's all very
you know, kind of smug and comedic.
Right and this again
is like this part of the perfect storm.
You kind of intimated it earlier is
while these conversations are happening online
it's the rise of social media
has this sort of incredibly powerful force.
And what it serves to do in this case is
like the culture of these boards is really shrouded all
in corner sort of irony jokes and like, you know, irony
poisonings, they call themselves.
Right and you're kind of trying to one up each other
with who can be the most deprived
and the way that 4chan works is the sort of rewards,
that kind of conversation.
It's really not that dissimilar to Instagram.
It just has different inputs.
Right but they're both essentially at the end of the day
social media tools that reward a certain kind of behavior.
And for Instagram, it's like, you know,
posing on a yacht or whatever that's gonna kind of film
at the most FOMO kind of reaction in the public.
And then on 4chan it's like, who can be the most brave.
And so that that's gonna be the edgiest.
It can be the edgiest.
And so, yeah, Pepe becomes like a great way to mask all
of this stuff and shrouded in this idea of irony.
But you know, you start repeating the same jokes
over and over again, and suddenly it becomes a lot easier
to believe these things, too, right.
And you mentioned at the very beginning
of the conversation this sort of moment
where frog Twitter happened
and it was this blip before gab popped up
where if you were someone who is into Trump,
a member of the alt-right,
you would have a little frog emoji icon
that you would put in your Twitter feed.
And it was this moment that actually politics
was getting commodified on Twitter, on social media.
It was this moment where all of a sudden politics
had a certain brand and all, you know
we are consuming these entertainment products
from Fox news, from MSNBC.
This is the team that we're on, this is my brand loyalty.
I'm either a frog Twitter, or I'm SJW Twitter
or I'm Rose Twitter or whatever.
And it's this sort of like taking
on of this like personal kind
of branding thing that really kind of flattens
out the conversation on social media.
And I think that people were responding
to this kind of knee jerk kind of consumerism attachment
to politics that was being amplified
on Twitter during that moment.
And, you know, Pepe just became an easy
like wink wink for that,
Right.
So on that subject of Trump's awareness
or perhaps his campaigns awareness around this trend
that's percolating up from a dark corner of the internet.
You've got this guy called Matt Braynard.
Who's the data chief
he's a strategist on the Trump campaign.
I think he was part of Corey Lewandowski staff, right?
Like pretty high up in the campaign.
And this guy has got like voter data wired
and he sees you're shaking your head.
Like, this is what I wanna hear about.
Like, 'cause he comes off as pretty tapped into, you know
how this whole thing kind of occurred
and presented himself in a way that, you know
he was the chief architect of making this happen.
I think like everything that happens virally
on the internet, and it's very hard to like take credit
for things but he's more than happy to do that.
I think what I will say that was important
that he brought to the film and why we wanted to talk
to him was really explaining how, like
why memes were powerful specifically politically.
Like he's the one that puts forth
this really interesting idea
that I think we're still needing to contend with.
But the idea that memes in politics has the net effect
of kind of democratizing political media.
So if you're just a single person sitting
behind your computer in Indiana
and you create the right meme
and the president retweets it all of a sudden
you're like at the forefront of the political conversation.
It's unbelievably empowering.
Completely to the point that Donald Trump
himself recognized that.
And over the last four years it's hosted several events
with like political memers.
So like he's very tapped in and aware
of how these narratives get built online
and how to kind of take advantage of social media
in that way.
Yeah and I think what Matt, I mean,
Matt is getting his data at the same place
that like the Obama people got their data.
I mean, if you've canvas for anyone in the last, you know,
decade, that they basically have like winnowed it down
to like who in the household might be a swing voter,
you know it's like,
they pretty much have every single neighborhood
in America locked in on who votes for who and when.
And so he recognized that there was this like
very slim margin that was there for these people
who were potentially open to Trump's message.
I think that was something that he did
kind of understand pretty early on that said,
you know, I mean he got let go of the Trump campaign
when they switched to Steve Bannon.
So I mean, I think that some of it was, I just,
they caught the zeitgeists at the exact right moment
you know, and that was something that I don't think
was like super premeditated on his part, you know
but he did say, you know, that like no one controls
Trump's Twitter Feed except him, you know
like Trump is the person, you know, in control
of that complete.
It's not like some group of guys, they I'm sure at moments
they were like, no, no, no, don't tweet that.
And then there
he was doing it.
Right.
So.
Well, Bannon exacerbates the whole thing.
The point is made in the movie that the whole position
was that the democratic party is not the opposition.
It's the media, that's the opposition.
And, that becomes a very, you know, kind of powerful idea
that I think, you know, allowed everything
that you talk about in the movie to be more potent
than it would have been Otherwise.
And then he also realized that there had been
this like incredible there'd always been this growing
Republican base connected to AM radio in America.
And that's a completely factionalized and extremely
angry group of reactionaries sort of Republicans.
And it was something that I think the mainstream
Republican party always kind of viewed from a distance.
It was like, ah, I don't know if we want
to totally go there.
Like we know those people are out there
and we know that they're voting, but at the same time
we don't necessarily wanna like, you know,
play to the crowd.
And then there's a moment where Bannon's like,
no we completely play to the crowd.
The crowd is the only thing that matters.
And so I think he just recognized that
and whether it was him just sort of knowing that
like he had this sort of army of Trump supporters
listening to AM radio 24 seven, or if he was just looking
at the Breitbart comment section, as people have talked
about as well, who knows,
but he recognized this was emotion.
People were coming to the rallies and they were way
more passionate about Trump than Hillary Clinton.
And he's like, how do we tap into this emotion?
And part of that is just galvanizing people through memes,
galvanizing people through getting angry at the media,
galvanizing people by telling them that they've been lied
to their whole lives and they should be angry about it.
And their anger is justified.
And he did a pretty amazing job at leveraging that.
Critically understanding also that we were in this moment
that you could sort of hack the media
that the way that the click-based media worked
and the way that Twitter and Facebook worked
is if you could just kind of create these moments
of virality that the pace
at which media now needs to publish stuff and create clicks
you could basically manipulate your own narrative.
Right and so that's the moment that Trump tweets
that smug Pepe I think is sort of like the harbinger
for this moment that we're still kind of trying
to make sense of at this point.
But if anything, like the film is really a story
about how these internet in reality is folded
into real life and how we're still trying
to like make sense of what is up and down.
Yeah meanwhile, the Clinton campaign
didn't seem to be nearly as clued in
as to what was going on.
It was misstep after misstep, you know, on some level
just blindly unaware of how powerful this culture
was that was sitting right beneath her feet.
Yeah that's actually like a perfect moment
for what I'm describing.
Right, you have this moment where Hillary Clinton
has this big political campaign event
where she's gonna sort of call out the alt-right
for the first time and really call out Pepe.
Right, completely unrelated.
A kid on 4chan happens to be attending this thing.
And he's like talking with people on the 4chan threads,
like, hey I'm at this Hillary Clinton rally,
what should I scream?
And you know of course the media is all there
and they're all like, oh you should yell this
or yell at this.
And then someone's like, yell Pepe.
Like, yell Pepe, yell Pepe, yell Pepe.
This is all happening just on an anonymous message board.
And like, it's this incredible event horizon
where like the internet fiction meets with real life
and then becomes the reality.
Right because what ends up happening is the--
And he yells at the exact right moment.
He yells Pepe.
It gets picked up by the TV cameras.
Hillary's talking literally about the alt-right
and before he even mentions Pepe at this point
and then like an hour later,
Rachel Maddow was on MSNBC talking about like
the Pepe moment
and then like history is solidified at that point.
But it all starts from like a very trolley place.
Yeah and 99.9% of people would see that
and not know what to make of that at all.
And yet it's so significant
and meaningful in that community.
Totally and it's really this moment they're like,
yeah politics ceases to be about kind of competing
for votes through ideas and really just about trolling.
Right like trolling as it turns out
as an incredibly powerful tool to coalesce movements.
Like if it's literally just about honing the libs
and just making people angry and the frog
this is a great way to sort of yeah.
Way easier thing to understand exactly.
It's a way you don't have to intellectualize
the feeling of trolling.
Exactly.
You don't have to intellectualize the feeling
of piling on someone when they're down.
Yeah and also Hillary had been someone who'd been the victim
of trolling for decades before, like, you know
the whole like feminazi thing that was happening
in the 90s she'd been named called
and sort of dragged, you know, for years and years and years
and this was kind of the culmination of that.
And I think, you know, I'm sure they had all the best
of intentions and what they were trying to do.
They were obviously trying to find a very convenient
and easy to understand way to describe what was happening
to the Republican party and Pepe to them
seem like a very easy way to explain it
and kind of at the same way that we decided to do it
but maybe much less nuanced
but what they critically misunderstood was, well
we all need to understand about how to deal with trolling.
It's like, you can't play to the trolls, right.
This is much to the delight
of people like Steve Bannon, that she did that.
Right 'cause you can just point it like,
oh, how ridiculous is this person she's talking about us
like into this green frog that's crazy, you know?
Yeah and no matter what you do,
it plays into their favor.
And so much of the energy has less to do
with political ideology than just like, let's see
if we can meme this guy into the presidency.
Like it's gamified.
The whole thing becomes a gigantic video game
of mass participation.
100%.
For sure.
Yeah and like, I think unfortunately, you know what
the past four years of borne out is like,
you can't build a society on that kind of cynicism.
Right, the COVID the things are real.
The internet is not real.
Things aren't real, you know what's real?
COVID, and you know what's real is like not responding to it
out of a completely grotesque, cynical nihilistic
perception of like how like society should operate.
And now we have like 3,000 people dying.
But that does go back to 4chan.
I mean, 4chan would talk, they would do these sort
of like they would coalesce to troll someone in some way.
And they would talk about how they're basically
like gaming reality.
Yeah.
You know, and it was this sort of idea that like
we can try to like use the internet to exert our will.
And then that will maybe that's for the lulls.
But in this case
I think it was very exciting to realize like
oh wait a minute we've sort of graduated
to the next level of this.
We can actually like gamify the system
and troll the country.
And you know, I think the way that they were sort of able
to get all of these memes coming off of 4chan
and then into these very like newly mainstream avenues
on Twitter is something
that was extremely potent.
Critically, you had a group of people
who all felt disempowered
who also felt like the internet was there
is that they created internet culture.
And now all of a sudden they're like,
oh this is how the media works.
We're actually in control of media.
We have PhDs in that level of disenfranchisement
suddenly becomes tremendous empowerment.
Like we were talking about a minute ago, like now it
and it's that trajectory from pacivity
into being completely plugged in.
Right and participating, not only participating actually
like being almost in charge
in some way of dictating results.
So they literally call it the memoir.
I mean it starts out again, it starts off as a joke,
but like, you know, it just it's cause playing
but like ultimately at the end of the day,
if that's all that animates your life,
like what's the difference between the joke and reality?
I mean we're viewing it the same way.
We watched it again.
We watched the movie again last night, just to get my head
around talking to you guys today.
And my wife, I've got two boys that are 24 and 25.
So they're big Redditors
like they have a pretty solid sense of all.
This is not news to them.
Right like they understand all this.
My wife was like, I don't understand what's happening.
And so it is like a foreign you're tapping
into like some strange, you know, ancient culture
that you've never been exposed to before that,
has its own rules
and its own language and vocabulary, you know, it's--
Yeah 4chan is very much about self
and the fall rising.
Yeah.
Does she understand that by the end of the film?
Well, she gets it, but she was still like,
it's so baffling, right.
To try to wrap your head
around that if you've never been introduced
to these kinds of communities and how powerful they are.
And that was really a big struggle creatively
was trying to figure out like
who is the intended audience for this film.
And then like once we decide that how much,
like explanation do we have to give so that people can
at least understand what the hell we're talking
about and become engaged in the story.
Yeah like deconstructing that and figuring out
how to communicate concisely and effectively
this story must've been challenging.
It was challenging, but like
it's dark as the story was, I mean
the collaboration was like pretty joyful.
I mean, it was something where we felt like, you know,
and we watched a lot of documentaries when we started
and we're like, we don't wanna do that.
We wanna try to do something different.
Let's try to like realizing
that we had all the mats artwork and Pepe
as a way to kind of like breathe new air into this story.
'Cause after Charlottesville there was all this different
media being put out and we just kind of wanted
to make something that was like stylistically distinct.
And then also felt like a movie
not just like sort of a long form essay or, you know
a work of journalism.
We wanted it to work like a movie.
So we have all of these, like this unique material
like Pepe dies in the movie.
How are we gonna approach that?
You know, is that something that we're gonna take seriously?
Is it gonna have a wink?
Like, is it gonna be all of those things?
And we knew that it could kind of give this film it's kind
of owned vibration that we're pretty excited about.
But yeah, we definitely like Giorgio was talking
about like the moment where someone yells Pepe at Hillary
like we tried that edit a bunch of different ways.
And then the first edit we did
we just had someone walking you through the moment
in a very like dry journalistic kind of way.
And they were like, let's strip the voice out.
Let's let the internet tell the story.
So we did that with no narration.
And then it's like,
well how do we put another layer of this?
Where we see that this information moves
off of 4chan pops
into the mainstream news pops onto YouTube
ends up on Twitter.
And it was this kind of like, oh, we're gonna
try to infuse these moments with as much stuff as possible
as many layers to the conversation.
'Cause we wanted the movie to feel
like it had a viral intensity to it.
Like you had a million tabs open
and you were looking at them.
Right
Right, right, right, yeah, definitely.
You've definitely succeeded in that.
I mean, there is an intensity to it
and you have a score that's very propulsive, you know
so you're very engaged and there's a tempo
to the whole thing, but it's also this beautiful art film
because the animation sequences are insane.
Like I mean, unbelievable.
Like what you were able to achieve
with that like really gorgeous, beautiful work.
Thank you.
Yeah that was
so talk about like how that,
how you conceptualized that
and how you figured out how to make that work narratively.
That was another big thing that we talked a lot
about in the beginning.
When we first thought about the movie
we maybe thought there would be like a lot more animation
in it because we felt like maybe the story
could hold a completely other sort of
kind of narrative, a thread.
And that was gonna have Pepe
and the boys club kind of going
on their own adventure and we would hear them talking
and they would kind of have their own character qualities.
And then we very quickly realized
that the movie just couldn't hold all of these ideas
the deeper we got into researching message boards
and the message board culture.
We just realized that if we started to insert these cartoons
in it, it was gonna steal away from the power
of the information.
Yeah.
And so we really need to figure out a way
to kind of like have the two things worth side by side.
But the other thing we really wanted to do is make it seem
like Matt's artwork had like a real sense
of stage presence to it.
We didn't want it to look like all the junky JPEGs
and the animated gifs on the internet.
We wanted it to have like its own life.
And so that was something that initially
like I'd never made a film before I'd done animation
on a film that Giorgio had made called
the "Owned, A Tale of Two Americas"
and enjoyed that process.
And then I was like, all right
but this is what I can kind of like try to bring
to the conversation.
So the animation works in the film in two different ways.
There's the world of 4chan and the motion graphics.
And that was really a way for me to research the film.
Like I had to take all of these 4chan posts
find them and then make them 4k.
So if I'm tracing them, I'm reading 4chan.
I'm downloading--
And also making one
of the ugliest websites on the planet looks cinematic.
Taking a Silkwood shower every night.
Absolutely, so, and then the cartoon part of it,
I collaborated with three amazing cartoonist
Kyland Woodrow, Jenna Carabello and Nicole Stafford.
And we really took Matt's comics as a jumping off place.
And sometimes we would just trace his comics
and make them animated.
And then other times we would really kind of
like use these characters and then figure out a way
to kind of like tell our own narrative.
And it was also just a way to kind of make the computer
seem, it was a way to tell it feels good man,
in a way where the computer
didn't have supremacy.
Right.
Like it is a cartoon, but ultimately we wanted a story
about how humans connect and you know, at the end
of the movie, the hope is that we, as humans can have
connection to each other at the end
and there's some spoilers we'll avoid,
but ultimately we're kind of returning Pepe to nature.
And as the animation crew and also Giorgio, co-wrote a song
with Sharon van Etten for that section that was like kind of
our gift to Matt and our hope that the movie wouldn't feel
like this, like dystopian essay.
You know, that it really had like a heart behind it.
The closing sequence where he jumps in the water
and then beautifully like swims up into the sun.
And did you write that song at the end?
I mean, that's an incredible song.
Yeah, it was.
Yeah I mean, it's the gift of having animation
be a part of this.
It's also a realization that it's really fucking hard
to end a documentary.
Yeah.
That's true.
And so like, we're like, well, we have this frog
and people have an emotional attachment to it.
Let's create our own emotional ride for Pepe.
So that like at the end there was different versions
of how we were gonna treat Pepe
but we always knew that the last thing
that the audience would see would be Pepe
because our hope was if we were decent filmmakers,
they would have their a newly found emotional attachment
to our Pepe.
And that like that could produce the waterworks.
Yeah, Giorgio is very quick to cry,
which is actually a good thing in the end.
No in the end I was like tearing up, you know
it's a very beautiful ending, but there's also a real world
a hopeful tone that struck at the end as well.
Yeah I mean, look that like everything we've been talking
about now has really just been about the impact
that internet culture has had on real life.
And this, the fact that like for years
in the early internet days, it was very clear delineation
between your real life person and your online life.
And like these two things have become really blurred.
And we're at a moment now where we have to decide
as a society, like which reality are we gonna push forward?
Right and the reality of the internet is that it is a place
at least in its current conception that teases out some
of the worst aspects in us.
Right it's a place where you're encouraged
to be as shady as possible to one another,
you know, and it's a place that like discourages
any bit of authenticity.
And so the film, the way we wanted to end the film as a kind
of stark reminder, that those are choices we make, right?
Like you don't have to engage the world in that way.
And a reminder that like you shouldn't be shamed out
of your capacity for empathy, which is kind
of what social media does to you on a daily basis.
Right and so those were the kinds of the emotions
that we knew that the emotional truth
that we knew we wanted the film to end on.
And it was just without spoiling the larger ending
like we were given a real gift in terms
of Pepe's transformation that happened in real time
while we were filming.
That's like, when you're making a documentary film
you can't plan for this kind of stuff.
And it's like such a amazing gift.
Yeah.
For sure.
So the film basically covers about two
and a half years, right?
From some point in 2017, through 2019, there's a lot
of focus on the Trump election as well.
But here we are in 2020, it'll be 2021.
When this goes up, knowing everything that, you know
now as a result of making this movie
and this archeological dig that you've done
on the internet and how it works, how do you reflect
on the election that we just went through
and the state of the internet currently in terms
of how we're communicating, how it's being weaponized
and how people are conducting themselves to either
you know, win an election or get their point across.
Yeah I mean the most obvious kind of parallel
is QAnon because in the same way,
Pepe sort of started out as this joke on 4chan
and then made its way into the mainstream.
QAnon started out as a joke on 4chan
was people sort of LARPing as intelligence officers.
And then all of a sudden this became something
that people were taking seriously.
And so, you know, the story of all of this message board
culture and trolling and stuff isn't insignificant.
And that kind of proves that.
But, you know, I think the story that we kind of tell
in the 2016 election is how trolling went mainstream.
And right now we're seeing how misinformation
has really gone mainstream.
And obviously they're connected
but it's something that I think we're all contending with.
And it's something that, I mean, we've talked a lot about
we're having a moment in culture where all
of the narratives that we've sort of taken to be true
are eroding this notion of American exceptionalism
is something that people are having to think about
in a critical way.
And that's really uncomfortable.
For the first time.
And so even if you, and that's, you know, the idea
of America being an exceptional place has always
been the thing that, you know, the right wing
in America has held onto is something that's sacred.
And right now through all of the protests that we're seeing,
the mismanagement of COVID, we're seeing that
like whatever sort of like sacredness you felt
towards America as being the special place is kind
of something you have to question.
And people are choosing to believe
in a fantasy rather than engaging with a reality.
And because you're on social media
and you're in these sort of siloed places
where you're not talking to people
with dissenting viewpoints
you're being fed kind of new things.
If you're into misinformation
you're getting fed more misinformation.
And also it's very hard to parse what's real and what's not,
you know, we're seeing kind of, you know,
the intellectual fabric of America road
and fray and, you know hopefully this is Pepe
and the story of "Feels Good Man"
is just like kind of a case study in which we can all kind
of start to have conversations about this.
That's our goal, you know?
Yeah I mean I hope
that the film is kind of a youth culture film.
That's certainly for people who are like under 35,
they feel like it's like,
there's much less translation issues.
Like they understand implicitly what the story is about.
And it feels like a youth culture movie
for their generation.
But it's been interesting to see older people's reactions
to the film,
because I feel like for a lot of them, they feel empowered
that they finally understand what's happening in front
of them in a way that felt really opaque and unclear.
But, moving forward we just are gonna have to like
realize that we have to,
I don't know, we've kind of incentivized bad faith operators
and put them in charge of our world.
And you have a media that still seems to like take those bad
faith operators in good faith.
And like that just has to stop.
Right, and self-awareness around it isn't enough.
Like that's not part of the solution.
Like we can all sit here and talk about it,
but meanwhile it just seems like it's getting ratcheted up.
Like when you compare 2016 to now it's night and day
and you know, the breakdown in our ability to effectively
communicate and the distrust of information sources
and the uncertainty around what's true and what's not true.
And, you know, disconnection that we're now experiencing
because of the pandemic, like all of these things
are contributing to, you know, denigration of the moral
fabric of society.
And I fear, you know, I've deep concerns
about how we're gonna see our way through this.
Even the people who are lording over the social
media platforms are befuddled
or insincere about the path forward.
Yeah, I mean, I feel like tech has to sort of come away
from this like startup model or this kind of like boom
and bust model and think about themselves more
as like a public utility
where there has to be different people sitting
on the boards.
There has to be at the SIS.
They have to realize that also, you know
this is affecting us here in the West,
but in the global South,
it's affecting people in an entirely different way.
You know, in those places where there's not as much
sort of infrastructure
this stuff is also raking a different kind of chaos.
And so, you know, obviously we have to have conversations
where, you know, we can't have just kind of like
the Silicon Valley boom and bust control the reality
of 7 billion people.
That's just not the way it's gonna work.
But also the irony, like I've never met Mark Zuckerberg
but I think he's, you know,
maybe not the most socialized person.
So there's just the idea that like our entire worlds
are being defined by kind of deeply antisocial people
is really problematic but like the way that we handle
and confront these issues needs to be taken
much more seriously.
Like on Twitter, you know, every tweet at this point
that Donald Trump puts out has that stupid
little notification below.
It's like being standing in front of a tidal wave.
Right.
It doesn't do it.
It's ineffective
You just have
to take them off.
And like, so many of the things
you talk about in the movie, it perhaps is even playing
into the hands of his base.
Totally.
Like that just
energizes them right.
To see that--
It's more us against them.
Yeah, you know, you just have to take it more seriously.
And, you know, I don't know
to the extent that you have to produce quarterly returns
for your investors.
Like I just wonder at what point, I don't know.
Yeah, well, the anonymous aspect of the whole thing
is a big part of this, right?
Like does 4chan exist if you can't post anonymously?
And there's a argument to be had that every buddy
who's saying anything on the internet
should get a blue check and be verified
so that you can basically legitimize who these people are.
And yet, you know, I had Bryan Fogel in here talking
about the dissident the other day and how important it is
for dissidents to be able to communicate from a safe place.
And that requires some level of anonymity in a place
like Saudi Arabia,
where 80% of the population is on Twitter.
And the only bastion of free speech is Twitter
because it's decentralized and can't be lorded over
by the control of the kingdom.
Yeah, I used to think verification
was a certain path towards, you know, positivity
but I will say like on all the social media platforms
probably the worst comments we get
are on Facebook.
Oh my God.
And like, I'll just click people's, you know,
it's a photo of a guy with his family, his two kids
from Valdosta, Giorgio who's just saying
like the most appraised worst chat about our film possible.
It's like maybe
that one will work.
Have you gotten
a bunch of negative blow back like that?
I mean, if you look at the comments on YouTube
or on Facebook, they're pretty predictable
Really, yeah.
But I have to say
that in terms of like our personal engagement with people,
it's been the opposite.
Like we've had actually a lot of people reach out and say
that the movie touched them in some way,
or they've been spending a lot of time on 4chan,
maybe when they were a teenager and they're in the process
of maybe aging out of it.
And the movie spoke to them in a really positive way.
You know, I also think like, you know,
even Pepe in the media has shifted
since we completed the film.
Pepe on Twitch is basically like
the de-facto mascot for Twitch.
He's back to being a reaction image for people
that are like excited or happy or angry.
So if you're on Twitch and you're looking
at the comments field
you'll just see like, you know,
chunks of Pepes floating by--
That have nothing
to do with like white supremacy
or anything.
Yeah, at all.
It's purely just for the walls.
So, yeah each platform kind of has its own
Relationship--
Take on things.
But no we've felt like actually we obviously had some
understandable fear while we were making the film.
But the reality is this is a conversation that people
are kind of ready to have.
And a lot of that like intense feeling
that people had about Pepe kind of evaporated
during 2016 and 2017.
And this is something that it's time for us
to all have a conversation about it.
Right--
'Cause, you know,
it's something our culture is experiencing and we have to go
through it together.
Right.
So you premiere the movie at Sundance,
which is super dope.
Like this is like, you've made one movie prior, right.
This is the first film that you've
been involved with it.
Yeah.
Right, so that's super exciting, right?
You guys are young guys, you make this movie,
you get into Sundance, you go,
you get crazy turnout standing ovation.
You get, you win this award.
Yeah, no, it was amazing.
I mean, also we got into Sundance with like storyboards.
So a lot of like the animations were just like
chicken scratch essentially.
And so we were just like sprinting to get the film done.
Yeah, but everybody does--
That is true,
that's like some of my favorite memories from the process
is those kind of like--
Sleepless.
Insane nights--
Right.
Yeah, that was like very emotional.
Like there was one night where I was like,
I think it was like five in the morning.
And we had like, we're trying to mix the film the next day
and it was just me and our Assistant Editor, Kaitlin,
in the office.
And I just told Kaitlin, I was like, "I'm gonna start
"To cry right now."
I don't know what else to do, you're just gonna watch me
and I'm gonna sit here and cry for like an hour
while we're editing and assembling things,
because it's such like this emotionally
kind of intense experience.
Sundance obviously was like a dream come true.
But then once you're kind of there,
you realize there's all these other sort of like--
Other people with dreams.
It's terrible.
True and you have many people.
And you also have to finish the movie and then like throw
a wedding for the movie at the same time
because you have to like have a party
and you have to make sure the party is at right time
so people will come and it's like, yeah
it's this really kind of very fun and surreal
but incredibly stressful thing.
And then also we're trying to like sell the film.
So it's kind of we're trying to present ourselves
as like, "Oh this is a product that we made,
"Please buy our product"
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a heavy experience.
You go in with the best of intentions
where like packed house.
Which theater did you premiere at?
The pioneer.
The pioneer, on a Monday.
Yeah like a Monday morning.
It doesn't matter what day it is when you're there though.
Oh, it actually does.
We found out--
I mean, if you wanna be--
you wanna be at Egyptian on Friday night or whatever.
Yeah, I mean the truth is like the big sales all happen
in the opening two days.
Right and so like, I think we recognized
was as soon as we found our Monday slot that like, "Okay."
I was like you though, I was like,
"Oh, we're just at Sundance."
Right.
"Everything is gravy, this is amazing."
But then it's like, people are like,
"Well, so-and-so can't come.
"And they might be interested in film."
Because it's Monday morning, specifically.
Oh man, the psychic of anguish, day by day.
People are just sort of chipping away at your enthusiasm
as you're kind of going into it.
And you know, I don't know, I'm a very like kind of private
self-conscious person,
like red carpet stuff
is like uncomfortable for me, for sure.
And so, there's a part of me that's also like,
"Well how am I gonna become like,"
I'm an animator.
I'm used to like being behind the computer in the middle
of the night animating.
I'm not used to sort of like standing up
and talking constantly and selling a film.
So that was like a pretty
heavy experience for me.
Right.
You know.
I discovered the movie,
I heard somebody talking about it and it just
lodged in my memory.
And so, you know, a couple nights later I searched for it.
I found it on Amazon.
I rented it, I watched it, but I did have to look for it.
Right, it wasn't front and center in my Netflix queue
screaming at me to watch.
And you know, as I said at the outset,
like, I really feel like this,
you know, this is a movie that everybody should see,
but I do think that it's suffering
from a lack of visibility and discoverability.
So can we talk about like the distribution aspect
of this whole thing?
I mean we agree with you--
And that's part
of why we're here.
I wanna help you guys out there a little bit.
Now the conversation
begins.
Yeah.
I mean we created our own like distribution company
basically to--
TO sell out the film.
We self-distributed the film, so we created a company
called Ready Fictions,
In part because you know, we did go into Sundance
and we'd heard a bunch of different stuff.
People that were interested in the film,
but I will say like, this was always a hard movie
to convince people to get behind.
And so we were able to make it independently
which was great
because we found, I mean, shout out
to Wavelength Productions,
they're an independent company
and they saw some early cuts of the film
and they always believed in us to make the movie.
And they have like been very supportive
but they were supportive in a way that like certainly
none of the platforms were supportive
and a lot of the other more established companies
that we presented the film to.
And in some cases you could feel like people slowly
backing out of the room as you were pitching the movie
because Pepe has this just knee jerk reaction.
When people see that frog, they're like, "Oh man."
You know, even one of the programmers at Sundance,
she was like, "You know, I had all these movies to watch
"For Sundance and then it was like the Pepe The Frog movie.
"Oh man."
And then she watched it
and loved it.
Right.
But that's been like a pretty common refrain.
And then when we went to sell the film we had a lot
of the same kind of moments.
Yeah and it's hard to know.
I don't know, obviously,
I'm sure there's like certain levels of assurances
that distributors wanna see, right.
You can pitch an idea,
you know, the idea might be interesting,
but they wanna see it finished, right.
So like when we were pitching the film,
people are like, "You guys had never really made a film
"of note before.
Yeah, it was understanding.
it was understandable, then we make this film,
it's like, we win this award.
We're like, "Okay, we proved it."
Like, it's a great film, it's getting great reviews.
So like, all right, now the offers are certainly
should be coming.
And then it's like Crickets.
So then you're like, you're never getting
a really clear answer from the streamers
who have like now kind of totalizing monopolistic
control over what people see.
You're not getting a sense of like
why they're passing on it.
But, you know, I dunno,
I would love to talk to someone about it
because the information we would get it was like,
"They really liked it, but it just wasn't a fit," you know?
Yeah, I mean, well aspiration is there--
That's disingenuous
Of course,
it's disingenuous.
I mean were talking about this before the podcast
and this also goes back to conversation
I have with Bryan Fogel and the struggles
that he has undergone trying to get his movie out there
because--
Yeah, after winning
an Oscar,
Right, he wins the Oscar,
you know, Netflix that's his team and they won't
touch the movie.
Amazon, you know, basically there's a whole
backstory to that.
And he thought like, well, Bezos will wanna be on board
with this because of the subject matter they pass.
And you realize that there's a big difference
between getting a domestic theatrical distributor
who's gonna put the movie
in some theaters,
Yep.
In the United States
100%.
And a streaming platform where it's instantly
globally available and these gigantic conglomerates
live and breed on expanding their subscriber base
in foreign territories.
And when you look at Saudi Arabia and you look at China
anything that is transgressive to those cultures
becomes radioactive to distribute, right.
It's just not worth it.
And it doesn't matter how good your movie is.
Like if that's gonna 'cause some kind of adverse reaction
in those communities or the political powers
that be it's just not worth it to them.
They're not gonna pass on it.
Yeah and as the industry pushes more towards
a subscription-based model,
I would assume that like, the stakes just
become much different, right?
If you're Universal and you're putting out
a film theatrically that's maybe edgy
people can boycott that film.
They're not boycotting Universal.
But if Netflix puts out a movie that they're maybe
aren't sure how it's gonna be received
and maybe has like a high level of potential for blowback
and people boycott the subscription it's like,
you know--
Right.
I can see how the stakes are much higher,
but all the same,
it's really scary to think as like an independent filmmaker
and storyteller like
as these platforms consolidate their power
like what it does to, and, you know, coming out of COVID,
seeing what's gonna happen to the theatrical market.
Like you said, without theaters basically independent cinema
doesn't exist, right.
You kind of have to prove yourself in movie theaters
as a viable thing.
It's also harder if you're a young filmmaker
Totally
Because there was always
this sort of like independent model.
Or even if you had like a small theatrical lease
or with a tiny, you know, sort company
you would still have kind of a way into the industry.
And so that's kind of actually getting harder,
even though there's more stuff.
And I think just realistically, like documentaries
are kind of at this transitional phase.
This year are some of the best films are documentary films
and they're breaking genre.
They're doing very interesting things.
And these streaming platforms really only care
about documentaries that are about like,
some of them are obviously news oriented,
but then it's celebrities and murder.
Right.
And so having this story
where if you have this tile of a green frog
on your platform,
you don't know which algorithmic sort of base
that is gonna to.
Right, yeah.
And we're in a gray area.
Yeah.
And so we were told, it was like too niche,
we were told that it was too political.
China definitely was something like,
at the end of our movie,
China became like something that scared some platforms away.
And then also it was just like, they were like,
"Oh well we already
have X movie--
About this.
Or Y movie.
Yeah and so people would never watch both of those.
Or the fact that we feel it might have its own merits.
We saw two movies about what was the party
in the Caribbean?
Oh yeah, The Fire Fest.
All right--
But I laughed to it
it was great.
I know.
Well, what was fascinating?
I wish I wrote it down
'cause I can't remember specifically what they were
but when we finish watching the movie,
Amazon shows you, you know, people who watch this movie
also like these movies and Trapper,
who is, you know, my a 24 year old, he was laughing.
He's like, "These movies have nothing
"To do with--
That's so funny.
That movie."
Like, it was a weird, like assemblage of bizarro film.
And that's the great irony
you're like you're kind of psyching yourself up,
like, "All right we're gonna do this.
"We're gonna sell it for this, our film."
And like, our EPS are on board, and like, that's incredible.
And everyone believes in this thing.
And you're like, "You know, fuck the system.
"We're gonna do this stuff on our own."
And then suddenly you realize that like,
you have to give Jeff Bezos every rental.
(guests laughing)
Right.
It's like Apple pass.
They're gonna
take your buddies--
No matter what.
Bezos as fast as that, Amazon's gonna take your bike.
Yeah and this moment where you're like for instance
one distributor offered a $0 for the film
and then they would commit to X number of marketing spend.
And that seems like offensive.
To me, it seemed like well, this sounds like I'm going down
to like a payday loan sort of scenario down the street,
but they can do it
because they know the path to selves to distribution
is so difficult.
And so we kind of thought that like, "Well we made
"This movie independently."
Like, you know, we have this kind of like mixed resumes.
So like, "Let's just do it ourselves."
So something where it's like, "Alright, we can cut
"The trailers, we can make the animation, we can figure out
"The strategy."
During this COVID moment we know as well as anybody
kind of how to get the film out.
Yeah and like the way that Matt leaned on his friends
to help him out,
we really have a lot of thanks to give to our friends
and friends of friends who really got behind the film.
Like, and even honestly, it was a very meager
little theatrical release by like Tim League
at Alamo Draft House.
I just sent him a cold email
as we were kind of contemplating this.
And he emailed back like almost instantaneously
and was like, "I'll help you
"However you want."
That's cool.
Yeah and like--
At all of them,
or just the one in LA--
Every one,
they could have opened in September.
And so we have like 12 screens,
but you know, that was super meaningful when you're
like wandering off into the wilderness.
The people that go to that place, that's your audience.
Totally and so, I don't know, hopefully like
if things get better, as soon as we can get back
into the theaters there,
but like, those are really meaningful moments that kind
of reassure us that we're doing the right thing
and the people give a shit.
Because at the end of the day,
like people are just in it to a point.
Like, it's hard to find.
It's hard to find
because there's just so much shit out there.
Yeah.
There some good shit, there's also a lot shit shit
but like, you have to sift through all of it.
And there's two morons at our own office,
like trying to figure out how to make this happen.
It's a daunting task,
but like slowly but surely it's you know,
I think it's, you know, a testament
to this--
Right.
The film itself is it just gets passed on.
The streaming platform thing is fascinating
in how it's kind of being accelerated through
this pandemic moment.
I mean, on the one hand, you know
when Netflix in the early days of Netflix, it's like
this is the greatest thing that ever happened
to a documentary filmmaker, suddenly all
of these films that would never get a theatrical release
or if it did, it would be in one art house, movie theater
for a week or something like that now are being consumed
by millions and millions of people.
And yet you have to, you know, take into consideration
at the same time that there is this weird
implicit chilling effect on free speech.
When they're not gonna platform films that are transgressive
in any way, that's gonna threaten the broadening
of their subscriber base.
And how does that bode for the future?
Right, you can always get it up like you guys did
but it does become a challenge to get people to see it.
And we were lucky.
I mean, we had the film is about a viral phenomenon.
So we knew that we kind of had Pepe
as like our best sort of advertising
chip for it.
That was all those people
that care about that.
Yes.
Hopefully.
We knew we had that as an audience
but I think for other films that for whatever reason,
you know, don't get picked up
by just like the four or five people who are the gatekeepers
for the entire industry.
It's a harder path because you have to convince people
to get behind the film, you know,
without having the most popular meme
that's ever been--
Right.
On the poster.
Right, Brian was talking about the idea--
That's crazy to hear about Brian did.
The dissonant was being edited while we were doing color
like watching the stress involved with that.
Yeah, I can't imagine.
I mean, yeah, the computer graphics animation sequences
in that movie I mean very different from yours, but also,
you know kind of amazing.
Have you seen that film?
I haven't seen the final cut.
I mean, yeah they were in the same color house.
So it was all the films that are going into Sundance
are getting all to the same place.
It's all like two in the morning
we're passing in the hallway.
I didn't see Brian, but I saw one of his producers.
Yeah but he had his idea was that there's a need
for a new streaming platform to serve these kinds of movies
that isn't about you know,
constant growth that can create some kind of revenue model
that makes sense.
And it makes it robust and profitable.
But the priority being kind of, you know, getting movies
like this out, that aren't gonna be
challenged in other ways.
The truth is that there are like so many
unbelievable documentaries that just will premiere
at festivals like Sundance that never get picked up.
And then just kind of like get lost in the shuffle and--
The whole world of the verite documentary.
Like there's a genre of doc that doesn't get picked up
by the platforms at all.
And it's just the verite style, which is just sort of
like letting life unfold in front of the camera.
And, you know, like there's this movie
"The Mayor That People Should Seek Out" by David Osit.
Who's about that movie is about the mayor of Ramallah
in Palestine, the Christian mayor of Ramallah in Palestine.
And that movie is an example of beautiful edgy
you know, verite, filmmaking, and, you know
those kinds of films don't make it onto the platforms.
And in part, because documentary is kind of having
a secondary growth moment and, you know
documentaries have a kind of always been funded
as if they're kind of like charity cases.
They're funded by sort of people who are like wealthy.
And this is almost like a donation they're making
but the reality is you're right.
Like there's a lot of amazing films getting made
and there needs to be like a platform
for them where people recognize like the financial potential
and like the artistic potential in them.
Right.
Yeah.
I talked to a software company is interested
in backing such a thing
for free.
Oh, that's cool.
In terms of
Yeah.
The grid lineage of donating to the cause--
Of just wanting to go straight.
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
We're ready to do it.
No, it's because we've been thinking
about the same thing completely because like
the information that we've gleaned from self releasing
like we wanna be able to teach other people how to do it
because it is daunting, but it is completely doable.
You just have to know what to do.
Especially like if the only thing--
That's what people
care about
That's kind of hard
to navigate, yeah.
Yeah.
Another thing at the end of the day,
no one's gonna care about your moving
more than you.
Of course not.
So in many cases, the best option really is.
I mean, that was a big mistake.
I think I made with my previous film owned is just
like selling it off for the first person who was interested
in like kind of shooting myself
in the foot rather than having done it myself.
Wow, but that's discouraging Brian
considering he did so well with, you know?
Yeah but I mean, I just, you know,
it just speaks to the, you know, tension around the subject
matter of the film for sure.
Which you'll appreciate
when you see it.
Yeah.
We got to talk about the arch Druid.
I'm not letting you out of here.
I hear a story behind that, dude.
Because I mean, how did you even find this guy?
Like what an unbelievable character.
But for me magic was something people
talked about in 4chan.
So for months before we found him
there was just a card on the bulletin board.
That was like meme magic
question mark.
Explain what meme magic is.
All right, just like the podcast.
Oh man you made the movie.
So we talked about earlier,
how 4chan likes to self mythologize, right.
And anytime it can see these coincidences or stuff,
it just regales and delights in any kinds of, sort of
coincidence that happened in real life that they've kind
of been talking about.
And so meme magic, I don't know,
you're better describing it.
So meme magic is basically specific to Pepe.
You know, they already have an emotional connection to Pepe.
Someone finds out that like
there's an ancient Egyptian frog god,
who's the god of chaos
and he's
an anthropomorphic frog
And his name is Pepe.
No, his name is Kek of Kekistani people.
That's all right.
But people on 4chan have always kind of taken memes
more seriously than the rest of the culture.
So, you know, and let's kind of like broaden the definition
of memes, not just sort of as like an image macro,
the way Pepe is or a cartoon, but even like something
as simple as make America great again
or a catch phrase or an idea that sort
of filters out through culture, fuck your feelings.
That's just, it's a meme.
Excuse me, just do it.
These are memes.
And so 4chan has always kind of considered themselves
to take this stuff as important
and realize that it's powerful and to realize that kind of
they also recognize that they're
like a community that has power with each other.
They're a congregation of people.
And if they're sitting in front
of the computer for 12 hours a day, looking at this stuff
there is kind of--
Putting shit
out in the world.
Putting shit out in the world.
There is kind of this quasi religious
projection that's happening.
So people on the boards will talk
about memes as being important.
And then memes also having
like some sort of esoteric significance.
Like these are symbols, symbols are important
they have history.
And so meme magic is something that people would talk
about on the boards kind of half as a joke
but half of it as a way to like self mythologize
and give importance to themselves.
And so when they started to use Pepe, they realized,
oh Pepe is sort of like our signifying meme.
He's sort of like our God.
Oh and then there is a Pantheon of Egyptian gods
and one of them is a frog and he's the God of chaos.
And we're a bunch shit of posters who want this chaos
to like you know, disseminate through culture.
And so people started to make all
of these Pepes that were kind of a mix
of just like historical religious iconography
a lot of it from Egypt, but a lot of, from other places too.
And of course this fits in with like the Illuminati
and all this sort of stuff.
And Pepe just kind of became this other
like kind of like focal point
for this kind of discussion that was happening.
And so people would talk about
like these moments we were talking
about where Pepe gets yelled at the rally and Reno
or the moment that Hillary falls
because people on 4chan had been trying to
like basically put it out into the world
that Hillary should be sick
and have this kind of medical event.
And these are moments of like kind of strange
confirmation for them.
And so people would talk about this as meme magic
or chaos magic.
And so initially we wanted to find someone that could talk
about this though, from a greater historical
perspective that would give the idea some gravity
so that it wasn't just someone who's talking about
shit posting in kind of a aggrandize, you know,
self-aggrandizing way.
And so--
But also in a way
then also in a way
that's like humor like in the style of the film too, right?
Because you're talking about meme magic
you have to accept the fact that it's a bit absurd
but you also have to accept the fact
that it's also like, I don't know.
It's like God, a true kind
of interesting connections are kind of funny.
And then, yeah, I just, I had happened to done a podcast
about my previous film and at the end of the interview
they asked me what I was working on next.
And we were trying to be mum about the project.
And I just said, vaguely, that we're doing a film
about Pepe and someone who had listened--
And I think I got mad at him afterwards.
I was like, you got to shut up.
That's not, that's actually very specific.
And then this guy emailed and was like,
hey if you're doing a movie about Pepe,
you should read the work of this guy, John Michael Greer,
who is an arch Druid.
And I Googled him.
And the first image that pops up is him as an arch Druid.
And he's got this incredible beard and I'm like,
oh boy I pushed us wearing a ceremonial.
Yeah.
And I sent it to Arthur
and then we started reading his stuff
and listening to him on radio.
I'm like this guy is actually like pretty incredible
and really brings a kind of seriousness
and intellectual honesty to the topic of magic really.
And he gave us a really incredible definition of magic
which really fits in very neatly to what the story's about.
Right, magic is about sort of people
you said better than I always felt.
Well I mean, he's sort of quoting this occultist named
Dion 4chan.
Right.
And he's sort of an acolyte of hers, but yeah.
They sort of talk about
obviously it's sort of all the trappings of magic.
That seems a little bit like Hocus Pocus
but this other thing that they're talking
about as much more serious, and that's the idea
that magic has always been the politics
of the unheard that if you are magic proliferates
and sort of happens within communities where they don't feel
like they have any agency in the world that they live in.
So it happened in like feudal situations,
it happened among slave cultures where people
didn't feel like they had agency in their own reality.
And so they would kind of create ceremonial ways
of like art and willpower, trying to affect their reality
in a positive way and also give them hope.
And so, you know, he talks
about Pepe as being a hyper sigil
that people are sort of pumping energy into.
And as we were talking to him
there was a moment where you're making a film
and you take chances on conversations.
You're gonna try out a voice in the film.
So we interviewed a lot
of people and they didn't make the cut.
And then when we interviewed him, there was just kind
of this like vibrational shift that happened in the room.
And it would also amazing, fascinating.
I was gonna say also, because like we had to go up to
Providence to meet him where Arthur went
to school and he happened to know
that this beautiful old library exists.
There were a Edgar Allen Poe.
I had no idea because there's like--
Did you go to Rusdy?
Yeah I went to Rusdy.
And there's a decrepit fountain in front of it.
And the joke would be like, you'd be coming out
of like a party and you'd be stumbling home
and you'd stumble past the library.
And if you drank from this decrepit fountain, that means
that you were gonna die in Providence.
And so there was always this thing where it's like,
oh you get drunk.
Did you drink from the fountain?
It means you're gonna die here.
But Providence has this like creepy witchy kind
of vibe anyway.
Right.
It's got HP Lovecraft, it's got Edgar Allen Poe.
And there was this like little private library, very
near the campus of Rusdy, and supposedly Edgar Allen Poe
had a crush on the librarian and he wrote some
of his like final poems there.
So he could just kind of like basically creep out on her.
But so we were able to film that with John
but John initially, you know, we'd booked it
and we didn't have much money.
So we booked it at 10:00 AM and I was like, all right, John
you got to get there at 9:00 AM.
'Cause it's cheaper to book in.
It was cheaper, and John was like, no, no no.
Like I won't be up until six or seven I'm nocturnal.
And so we ended up spending a little bit
of more money to film him at night
but it just kind of elevated the whole thing
into like a V it also just, we we've been doing this run
of like interviews and I think we were kind of feeling
like tired and then that just kind of reinvigorated--
Totally.
Yeah. I mean, I think within five minutes of the interview
like I was just covered in goosebumps and I just walked out
of the library to go to the nearest liquor store
to buy him a really nice book Whiskey.
'Cause it was just like, I knew we had it
like it just his presence of the film is the sum total
of everything we were trying to achieve with the film
which is riding this line of utter, complete stupidity
and the most like serious, important conversation.
'Cause there's an absurdist total aspect
to the whole thing.
But actually what he's saying is powerful.
And he was such a great sport about it too.
Like he was very self aware of why he was there.
He gave us incredible.
He was only a 30 minute interview was unbelievably efficient
and like what he was able to do
but also like was really helpful
in like leaning into the jokes.
Like you let us do this little one.
But he also gave us like,
he kind of brought like another kind of idea
into focus when we were editing the film.
And that was this moment.
And you sort of talked about Matt Braynard earlier
where it's like he presents himself in a certain way.
And so while we were making the film, we're like, all right
let's give the audience these moments
where they have to decide we're coming from
and whether they're choosing to take this person seriously.
And so with John Michael Greer
it's this kind of like litmus test thing.
When people watch the movie, a lot of people are like, eh
I don't know the movie kind
of the documentary went off the rails in that moment.
I don't know why they inserted this guy.
And then other people are like, oh, that's my favorite part.
And it's also Matt Fury's favorite part.
I was gonna say to you.
That's not surprising.
Yeah but, and that was kind of part of it too.
It's like, who would be kind of the voice for this for Matt?
And it seemed like he was the right dude,
but it's this kind of like lean in moment where it's like,
all right what are we wanted the audience to be like,
all right am I taking them seriously?
Why did the filmmakers choose to put him in there?
It's this moment where it's like
our audience member is gonna feel
like engaged with the subject matter
in a way where they might choose to disagree
with us for a second and then come back to it.
And we thought that was kind of
like a very interesting device to use--
Yeah.
In the movie.
Well, I mean he's certainly a guy
that I'd like to have around once in a while
to call on for advice, you know like it would just be cool
to have that guy in your circle.
But beyond that, what I took from what he had to
say was that there's power in group consciousness.
Like you can call it meme magic, but when you have millions
of people whose mental energy is aligned in a certain way
and they're trying to manifest a certain result
like that's something that you cannot overlook.
Like that's a hugely powerful thing
because that translates into the behaviors and the actions
that those people are gonna take.
Yeah completely and we were talking about
how this frog just caught the imagination
of the group of people.
So yeah, the occultist is gonna bring it all into view.
Yeah, how do you, I look at this movie in certain ways,
it's very different from this other movie
that I was gonna mention but they kind of are like cousins
in a way.
Like, how do you think about the social dilemma
and how this movie fits in with that one?
Like, I feel like those two movies could be watched back
to back as companion pieces to each other.
Yeah I mean, I think they're both, I mean
as we've talked about media literacy
I think the social dilemma is a super effective film
especially if you're like a young person
who maybe hasn't thought about your phone in a critical way.
And so I do think that like, I mean
that's why they'd be so great
if they were sitting next to each other
on Netflix.
Right.
I do.
That does.
Yeah.
I mean, Don Harris was on a tax Shepherd's podcast
recently and Decks, thankfully, thank you, Decks.
Matt she mentioned your film
that might've been where I heard it first
'cause I listened to that interview.
But then Don hadn't seen it yet,
which is like a real bummer.
It's like come on.
Well, I think it's good that these
I think it's good that a lot of people
are watching these kinds of movies
because I do think that like we were saying before
social media is something that we have to be critical
of as a culture.
And we have to realize how we are all susceptible
to this kind of like machine learning
and the echo chambers that we find ourselves in.
And so obviously his movie like, you know
the social dilemma kind of tackles that
at a little bit more head on
and our movie is kind of like a little bit more spread out.
It's got this artist journey story mixed
with this kind of cultural critique.
But, you know, I do think
like Giorgio mentioned that, you know,
"Feels Good Man" is a little bit of a youth culture movie.
I think they both are.
I think they're movies that are gonna kind of
like kind of open people up to a slightly different way
of understanding how they ingest social media.
And I think that's really good, you know
and I also think that if you liked the social dilemma
you should read the books of Douglas Rushkoff.
Why is that?
'Cause those guys are repeating what Douglas Rushkoff says
in his book, like throwing rocks at the Google bus.
So, and there's always been kind of, you know
Douglas Rushkoff represents this voice
of the earlier kind of internet critique.
And that critique has always also been kind of like bundled
into this other notion that this could be
like an economic revolution as well
in that there can be a more peer to peer version
of our economy.
And we're having this moment
during the pandemic where it's like
we're discovering that our economy, which seems
in some ways to be doing very well
like the stock market is doing very well
that our economy doesn't need workers anymore.
It only needs consumers.
And it's this other model that
in order for all of this stuff to change
we have to realize that some of the economic underpinnings
of our culture have to shift and change
and that's gonna be a slow and kind of painful process.
But ultimately it leads to kind of hopefully
a more democratized system that we can all be part of.
But we're just realizing
that that has to be like intentional
that we have to like start to make decisions
and realize that this is not gonna be like, you know
it's not gonna be the matter
of a couple social media platforms, changing their sort of
you know, flagging of truth or conspiracy
that it's gonna be like a series of like smaller
very intentional decisions made over a long period
of time by a bigger group of voices
in order for this to really change the, you know
Silicon Valley does have to figure
out a way to be more inclusive
because it is like it's ultimately like affecting cultures
across the globe and it needs to reflect that
it needs to have like more diverse voices in those rooms.
And I think that ultimately we're
in a transitional moment right now, and
that if we sort of are able to understand the truth
that like the social dilemma holds or "Feels Good Man"
points to that we can have like a greater intentionality
over this that we can sort of like not give into
the machine learning and realize
that we have kind of the ability
to have the world be a better, more humane
more human place because of the internet.
And so I think we're just at this moment
that's really confusing and I hope we pass out of it but.
Yeah, I mean, that's very beautifully put
and I think a good place to end it
but I can't end it without bringing it back to Matt.
And I think what strikes me the most about him is, you know
despite the fact that he goes on this journey
and he has these emotional peaks and valleys
he never loses sight of his core value
which is to be optimistic
and to always kind of double down on love, right?
It's like, he ends the film
by saying you got to go hardcore happy and that's, you know
clearly the message that you wanna leave people with.
But in order to get there
we have to, you know, experience this, you know,
this very cynical situation that you document
this garbage world to use Matt's words
but ultimately you end up, you know,
in this kind of hopeful place, right.
So is that how you look at this now?
Like, were you able to, you know
go through this whole process
and come out of it optimistic about the future?
I mean, I think you have to be
because that's how trolling works, right?
It only works if it strips you of hope
and subjugates you to the idea of cynicism.
And so, you know, the reason we wanted
I think when we first interviewed Matt, you know
he said that hardcore happy sentence.
And then maybe in the context of the interview
it felt maybe a little hippy dippy
but then when we place it at the end of the film
it kind of imbued it with a level
of power that I wasn't personally prepared for.
It always kills me every time I watch it
because there's kind of a wincing when he says it
because like depression is obviously a very real thing
and can't be dismissed
but there's also a truth to how you engage the world.
And that there's choices that you make about that.
And Matt's choice is hardcore happiness.
And like, if you don't make that choice
you're kind of like on a path towards the basement.
Right and that's like, one of our characters
kind of represented in I think he's someone who feels
trapped that the person, the basement person,
he feels trapped by a machine
that he feels like he can't get out from under.
So I don't know.
I think I totally subscribed
to the hardcore happy catch phrase.
It's not hippy-dippy because I think
like Giorgio was talking about this wincing moment.
He's talking about the look on Matt's face when he says it.
And it's this moment where, you know
Matt does have this sort
of acknowledgement that this is a choice
and that it's not an easy choice to make.
And it's a choice that constantly takes
like recalibration within all of the sort
of things that are happening throughout your day, you know
but we do think that the movie
our hope for it is that like, you know
anonymous people on the internet have used Pepe anonymously.
And you kind of imagine that to sort of all happen
within a vacuum
but the reality is there is sort of a ripple effect.
And so if you see the way that the use
of Pepe has affected Matt and his family
if you see if you were able to kind of observe that
maybe they'll just be like this like subtle kind
of shifted perception that you have.
And I think that that's was kind of our goal
in the end of the film.
And I feel, I dunno, I'm someone that has
I felt hopeful just from making the film
from working with the people who are so passionate
while they were making the film
those collaborations are actually have like
kind of reinvigorated me.
You know, I don't know how I feel
about the future of social media though.
That's something that I don't know if I have the same sort
of optimism, but I'll keep that to myself.
You guys, are you on social media?
Yeah I am.
He's a Twitter guy.
You are okay.
Yeah.
We'll end it with that.
But what are you working on now?
Like what's next for you guys?
Well, we're still in the--
Yeah, yeah, no, we don't wanna talk about it.
I don't know.
We are working on an animated series or developing with it
with a comedian that I think has a lot of hope hopefully.
And writing projects.
I think we're gonna take next year to really
like generate new ideas.
But if anyone wants to hire us, tell us.
You guys are working together now right?
Yeah, yeah, cool.
Well, it's a powerful duo, thank you.
Thank you very much, I really appreciate this.
Yeah, like I said, I love the movie.
It was better the second time watching it the other night.
I can't stress enough how everybody who's watching
or listening should check it out.
Please do the best place to do that.
I mean, there's feelsgood.movie.com, right?
It's feelsgoodmanfilm.com
I really put you back, didn't I?
I got that totally fucked up.
It was a value up to that, we appreciate it.
But you're on Amazon obviously, you're on Apple TV.
I just, as a point of, 'cause I didn't know this
until we self released, but so Amazon takes 50%
of the take and Apple takes 30%.
Oh, go forth on calculation.
Those two places though, right.
And everywhere, a lot of Vimeo, it's a bunch of
we have a link tree on the website.
Cool and if you wanna connect with you guys individually,
you're on social media, right.
We're both on Instagram.
You are?
Yeah.
I think you have to be.
That's true about that.
Not being coy, it's just a private account
but I'll probably accept you, yeah.
Yeah but we, you can email us through the website
we respond there's no--
Yeah we have a lot of conversations with people
that have watched the movie and they're always
fascinating.
Yeah cool.
Well, best of luck you guys.
Thank you so much for you.
If there's anything else I can do, please let me know.
Thank you, man really appreciate it.
Alright.
Peace.
Peace, "Feels Good Man".